[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission où
on parle alimentation agriculture
écologique mais aussi politique et cette
semaine nous recevons violette spielboot
bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et avec moi pour présenter
cette émission Jean-Pierre Montanet
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour Brigitte
vous êtes député renaissance du Nord
porte-parole du groupe écorra porteur
d'un rapport sur l'éducation critique
aux médias après des études en santé
publique Vous vous tournez rapidement
vers la politique votre mentor Pierre
Mauroy vous êtes alors chargé de mission
à la mairie de Lille en 2008 vous
devenez directrice de cabinet de Martine
Aubry 4 ans plus tard vous la quittez à
grand fracas sur un désaccord elle
deviendra votre pire ennemi retour à la
vie civile à la SNCF mais toujours à 100
à l'heure et piquer du virus de la
politique vous replongez avec une
motivation remplacée Martine au battu à
la mairie de Lille en 2020 il se dit
déjà que vous pourriez être candidate en
2024 et votre menu très très chi montre
que vous êtes peut-être déjà en campagne
n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre
une recette du Nord le patch levelh je
l'ai bien prononcé c'est pas mal même
moi là des fois j'ai des difficultés
au spéculoos dans le dessous des plats à
la découverte d'une des meilleures
frites du Nord David nous a livré tous
ces secrets pour une frite dorée et
croustillante dans les pieds dans le
plat la bière artisanale pétille on en
boit de plus en plus reportage au cœur
d'une ancienne brasserie ressuscité
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
alors d'abord sachez de l'aide spielboot
que je suis déçu et je veux me livrer à
une modeste psychanalyse de comptoir
lyonnais comme vous vous êtes dans le 6e
comme moi j'imaginais que vous étiez
donc biberonné au gradouble et au
tablier de sa peur de la capitale de la
gastronomie je comptais bien sur votre
innée sur vos gènes Lyonnais pour
déguster avec Brigitte un maçon ce
casse-croûte servi entre René Saône dans
les bouchons et bien non figurez-vous
que tout ça a été balayé par votre
acquis et votre immersion dans le Nord
donc pas de quenelle en mode berbrazier
aujourd'hui mais une recette flamande au
nom on l'a vu un prononçable le patch
lovelech ou patchleich il y a plusieurs
expressions plusieurs façons de le dire
on va donc faire comme nos voisins
belges pragmatiques qui le surnomme le
pote littéralement Brigitte pot de
viande recette qui en dit long sur votre
intégration express et profonde au pays
des chtis car ce patch assemblage de
trois viandes blanches est une
spécialité
iconique séculaire qui nourrissait 14ème
siècle les moissonneurs alors je veux
savoir si ce plat là en particulier ou
si c'est toute la culture du Nord qui
vous a fait oublier vos racines
bon alors Jean-Pierre déçu mais
finalement c'est mon histoire c'est que
je suis né à Lyon mais je n'y suis pas
resté plus de 15 jours 3 semaines
c'était un passage et ma maman a
accouché un peu plus tôt que prévu et
mes parents ont remonté vers
Clermont-Ferrand donc j'ai vécu mes 10
premières années à Clermont-Ferrand
plutôt en Auvergne et puis mes
grands-parents maternels les parents de
ma maman est habité rue Barthélémy de
l'épaule à Lille donc votre histoire
elle est lilloise
j'ai été en CM1 à Lille et je n'ai pas
quitté l'île avec quelques
allers-retours à Paris professionnel
selon les moments de ma carrière mais on
peut dire que je suis une fille du Nord
est une très belle ville mais quand même
les nordises ils ont la chaleur dans le
cœur et on verra
je vais pas les critiquer mais c'est sûr
que moi je suis fière de ma région et
j'ai envie d'en être l'ambassade alors
là oui là on a bien compris
c'est difficile mais c'est vraiment la
spécialité du côté de Lille ou dans le
Nord alors il y en a plusieurs moi
pourquoi j'ai choisi ce plat d'abord
parce que je l'aime et que je le
commande assez souvent des fois c'est
avec des frites des fois c'est frites
salades ça c'est plutôt la tradition et
des fois quand je fais un peu attention
je fais poche salade ça c'est les gens
parce qu'il y a pas de gras c'est
vraiment à la fois un plat à base de
viande froide donc il se mange froid on
ne voit pas la télé mais c'est froid
avec un peu de de gelée autour pas mal
de gelée des petits légumes des carottes
des oignons il y a plein chacun à sa
recette et c'est des viandes froides qui
sont parfois avec des eaux parfois des
œufs vraiment il y a des variations dans
cette recette mais c'est vrai que c'est
une recette ancienne simple qui avait
été créée par les marins du côté de
Dunkerque pour conserver la viande
d'abord dans le sel puis après avec la
gelée c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
conserver dans son frigo quand on a du
rab et c'est quelque chose qui sert dans
beaucoup de restaurants lillois mais
c'est pas la seule spécialité ce qui est
le plus connu c'est peut-être les moules
frites et la carbonade flamande voilà
moi celui-là c'est mon préféré alors
pour vous difficile d'en trouver à Paris
du poche love lèche mais on l'a trouvé
on a ramené spécialement du Nord goûter
le dites-nous alors moi je trouve ça
ensemble et c'est un plat d'été en fait
parce que comme c'est frais avec une
petite pomme de terre au four c'est
délicieux
et pendant ce temps-là Brigitte moi je
vais vous donner trois petits alors je
connais rien sur le patch lovelech à
part les Nordistes personne de sexe
pour essayer quand on est pas acheté
qu'on n'est pas nordiste de ce sacler à
cette recette alors d'abord c'est
compliqué à dire mais finalement c'est
assez facile à faire mais on m'a dit que
c'était très long donc si vous voulez en
déguster avec des amis samedi le samedi
Brigitte il faut voilà la veille alors
ces morceaux de viande c'est des viandes
blanches donc c'est facile à reconnaître
lapin poulet et porc vous les dites
parfois il y a du veau c'est une vente
blanche vous les disposez dans une
terrine mais attention il faut ne pas
les désosser il faut les couper en
morceaux mais surtout garder les os
parce que c'est ces os qui vont
permettre ensuite à la gelée de prendre
vous mettez vos aromates violettes à
parler de tomates on peut mettre aussi
des épices et puis du lard la couenne du
lard des rondelles de carottes des bêtes
genièvre et puis surtout de la bière et
on va verser de la bière jusqu'à ce que
l'avion soit complètement inondée et
puis ensuite on l'a fait cuire alors une
astuce vous la mettez au bain-marie et
vous la faites cuire à 150 degrés
pendant trois heures trente quand même
ça vous le saviez 3h30 et sinon ça
c'était une cuisson longue on le voit
d'ailleurs il est très bon
lente et du coup c'est c'est
fondant et puis on sent que il y a
beaucoup de parfums dans ce très
longtemps au frigo puis ensuite on a des
moules et on a cette espèce de gelée
voilà c'est une terrine et qu'on a coupé
avec cette gelée un peu un peu imbibé de
bière mais on sent l'amertume moi
j'aurais dit que c'est du vinaigre c'est
la bière en fait il y a plusieurs
recettes mais c'est vrai que la bière
est assez souvent dans le pochevêche la
recette la plus connue la plus la plus
médiatique c'est celle de chez Pierrot
parce que Pierrot c'est c'est quelqu'un
à Lille et une institution et qui lui
l'a fait avec l'anneau stocké qui est
une bière qui a été primée meilleure
bière du monde en 2016 qui fait la
fierté des Flandres qui est aujourd'hui
très à la mode dans tous les endroits
branchés à Lille mais aussi à Paris vous
allez trouver cette belle bière flamande
et il a proposé ça comme ça et on peut
la commander en poudre on peut acheter
aussi du pochelevage déjà en pot qu'on
regarde longtemps
on peut l'acheter et on peut le vous
savez le faire vous
alors moi j'ai déjà fait des carbonades
parce que c'est facile on fait deux
trois jours avant en fait ce qui est
vraiment bon comme beaucoup de place et
le fait de mijoter de mettre au chaud et
puis de refroidir et puis d'attendre le
lendemain et donc de le faire chauffer
voilà c'est plus ma spécialité le poche
il faut surtout bien savoir choisir les
viandes pour qu'elles soient fondantes
sans trop de gras mais juste un peu faut
savoir faire prendre la gelée donc c'est
une technique de grand-mère et alors ce
qui est amusant c'est que ça se sert
avec des frites chaudes ce qui est un
peu contradictoire quoi ce chaud froid
pourquoi en fait
la gelée fonce c'est ça avec les frites
chaudes
c'est vraiment une recette du Nord très
connu un ce pain demi avec ou sans
jambon avec le cheddar fondu très lourd
très gras on rajoute des frites aussi
vous voyez donc dans le Nord il y a
quand même cette tradition de l'Afrique
donc c'est vrai que c'est un plat qui va
vite on sort du frigo on fait une frite
hop on on a un repas qui est prêt c'est
populaire c'est pas très cher parce que
c'est des viandes blanches avec du porc
en plus
des fois ça peut être des restes de
poulet aussi donc voilà c'est quelque
chose de une recette simple comme je les
ai plat d'hiver ou plat d'été en fait
moi j'en mange tout le temps toute
l'année parce que l'hiver on a
l'impression de manger un peu plus léger
c'est à dire qu'à côté des frites on a
un plat et c'est pas cuit dans le bras
c'est plutôt du bouillon donc c'est
hyper léger et puis l'été c'est très
frais avec une salade maintenant c'est
surtout vous pouvez le garder longtemps
au frigo si vous faites un barbecue ou
des choses comme ça vous pouvez avoir à
côté un poche voilà vous avez durable
vous savez que ça peut conserver des
jours d'après alors vous parlez bien de
la nourriture vous êtes une experte mais
jamais au fourneau ou très peu
un restaurant vous m'avez dit
vous avez des spécialités j'imagine bah
alors la carbonade je l'ai souvent faite
les plats mijotés j'aime bien parce que
c'est aussi une question d'organisation
quand on travaille beaucoup on prépare
les plats à l'avance quand on reçoit des
copains et puis moi j'aime bien quand je
reçois des gens être à table avec eux
pas être tout le temps au fourneau donc
j'organise un peu à l'avance le chili
con carne c'est quelque chose aussi que
j'aime bien parce que ça plaît
non pas du tout c'est que ça plaît
autant aux adultes que aux jeunes aux
enfants enfin c'est un plat hyper
familial qui plie un peu à tout le monde
qui peut être préparé à l'avance pareil
mijoter deux trois jours le temps moi je
travaille dans le temps longue durée
le travail de fond ça permet voilà
d'être réchauffé s'il y a des restes
pareil on gâche pas moi je fais souvent
attention quand même à ça
moins la dose
les sautés de veau les plats un peu
traditionnels j'ai mes petites habitudes
je fais des des tartes la flammation
Maroilles c'est bon
voilà les quiches quiche lorraine des
quiches au saumon des tartes aux légumes
les tartes à la tomate l'été qu'on peut
manger froide les pissaladières des
choses que vous avez une belle palette
une relève de merde de famille classique
je vais vous dire je suis pas une grande
spécialiste j'aime bien la cuisine mais
cuisiner vous n'achetez pas tout faire
ou j'achète ainsi des gens qui sont
faits maison
qu'on appelle ça transformer des
lasagnes transformer des pizzas
transformées ah bon comme ça ça m'arrive
quand je l'ai au congélation
en terme de malbouffe mais en même temps
on n'est pas beaucoup à la maison on a
le sujet de la gestion du du frigo
familiale d'être député au sens où vous
n'avez vraiment plus le temps de
cuisiner vous vous faites vraiment la
différence ah oui vraiment la différence
et puis surtout le week-end je suis
beaucoup en circonscription à Lille la
Marcq-en-Baroeul à Bondues j'essaye
d'être sur le terrain avec les gens
alors je mange toujours autant parce que
quand on rencontre
les barbecues du centre social de
Marcq-en-Baroeul il y a les frites
effectivement
quand il faut
faire plaisir à ses autres donc ouais
c'est un si j'ai bien mangé ou des
gaufres dans une braderie le soir je
mange pas en fait une fois qu'on est
rassasié un repas de repas par jour ça
suffit mais en tout cas voilà plus en
circonscription donc on a fait le choix
quand je dis on sait aussi ma famille
mon mari celle de mes filles qui vit
encore avec nous de voilà quand on est
investi politique
et encore plus aujourd'hui où les gens
ils ont besoin de confiance de proximité
je suis beaucoup sur le terrain donc je
suis moins à la maison
mon mari il cuisine une fois s'il a des
Saint-Jacques mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas son truc la cuisine donc sinon ben
on se fait une bonne tartine je vois là
une baguette une tartine une petite
terrine un saucisson des rillettes de
thon des choses simples et puis faites
pas très attention aux calories à votre
poids si vous faites attention à ça si
les tendances je suis une famille
flamande donc j'ai tendance à prendre
facilement du poids et en plus avec
l'âge on prend de plus en plus vite donc
je voilà je suis une bonne mangeuse je
suis gourmande
j'essaye de me priver de dessert
quasiment tout le temps c'est ça votre
je pense que le sucré le sucre moi
j'adore les tartines de beurre hier soir
on avait une réunion de travail avec des
députés sur la décentralisation et les
la répartition des pouvoirs entre l'État
et les collectivités territoriales et
c'était charcuterie fromage moi j'adore
quoi ah oui mais j'en ai beaucoup
d'autres
ce matin j'ai mangé quelques fruits j'ai
équilibre et vous et vous ne buvez pas
de vin parce que vous nous avez demandé
du kombucha alors le kombucha pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas
là c'est le Love kombucha qui est une
spécialité qui vient du nord et à côté
de l'île c'est une boisson fermentée qui
est à base de thé acidulé finement
pétillante les fermentés donc avec des
avec des levures des bonnes bactéries
qui peut contenir éventuellement un
petit peu de traces d'alcool puisque
c'est fermenté mais très très peu quoi
et sinon c'est bio et il y a ça peut
être au thé vert au thé noir là c'est
Ginger donc au gingembre citron menthe
il y a un peu de tout c'est une boisson
que vous affectionnez particulièrement
alors c'est assez récent j'ai découvert
ça dans un restaurant l'année à Lille
Marcq-en-Baroeul dans ma circonscription
j'essaye de faire alors ça c'est bien je
fais marcher le commerce local donc je
vais faire mes courses dans ma
circonscription et j'essaye d'aller voir
tous les restaurants de discuter aussi
il y a eu le sujet de l'énergie tout ça
voilà donc le fait d'aller manger dans
ma circonscription c'est plutôt un
plaisir et des belles rencontres et donc
à l'annexe à Marc qu'ils avaient ce
Loven combucha qui a une marque de
conducteur il y en a d'autres et j'ai
regardé un petit peu j'ai regardé sur
Instagram leur site j'ai vu que ils
avaient créé ça à l'île assez récemment
ça se base quand même sur la tradition
brassicole voilà ce que ça se fermente
ils disent brasseurs de combustion ce
qui est intéressant c'est une boisson
plutôt détox au départ qui était qui est
j'utilise des bactéries des levures mais
aussi on a les fabricants de levure chez
nous dans le Nord avec le safre donc
tout ça fait que c'est un vrai produit
local c'est un produit qui est bon pour
la santé peu sucré qui remplace des
sodas et moi j'aime bien varier les
boissons donc voilà avec les plats ou
c'est plutôt à l'apéritif vous savez moi
je bois aussi du coca zéro avec les
plats donc j'essaie d'arrêter
le matin au réveil un bon verre de Love
Kong
je ne bois plus d'alcool j'ai décidé que
j'arrêtais la cigarette et l'alcool
parce que j'ai envie de de vivre
longtemps bonne santé donc de me donner
les meilleures chances et puis ça me
fatiguait l'alcool moi j'ai tendance un
peu à être excessive je suis entière
donc moi j'aime j'aimais bien voilà donc
avec les copains
ça me convient bien comme ça je sentais
en meilleure forme voilà on essaie de
garder de la convivialité au départ
j'étais un peu inquiète la vie avec les
autres et puis finalement la vie sans
alcool en tout cas tous ceux qui ont
envie d'arrêter je dis on se sent bien
plus en forme même c'est ça
quand même sociale du vin à table dans
dans les Guinée je trouve que je trouve
franchement que quand on est assez ferme
sur ses choix et qu'au si on est sympa
avec tous ceux qui boivent du bon vin
puis c'est quand même la tradition
française nos bières dans le Nord moi je
trouve qu'il y a très très peu de
pression finalement puis des fois quand
j'ai pas envie d'expliquer je goûte un
peu bien sûr quand on m'offre un petit
Verreaux dans ces justement quand vous
baladez dans la circonscription vous
tend toujours un verre de 1 la première
chose qu'on vous fait c'est et donc vous
avez su résister mais franchement au
bout de cinq ans c'est plus un sujet
dans ma vie après je dis pas que ça peut
pas arriver mais moi je trouve même dans
une fonction politique pour tout vous
dire on est en permanence confronté à
l'alcool l'alimentation
en même temps on a des vrais sujets de
santé tous dans nos familles on a des
gens autour de nous
mon papa il est décédé d'un cancer du
poumon on a des gens qui des problèmes
avec l'alcool donc moi je trouve qu'en
tant qu'élu moi ça me fait du bien en
tout cas je donne pas de leçon aux
autres je crois que c'est ça qui est
important ça me va bien comme mode de
vie et en même temps il y a pas ses 100
tentations et je pense que c'est
important de pas avoir une réputation
non plus quand on est une femme en
politique faut avoir du sérieux donc
voilà une question aussi sur la viande
est-ce que vous mangez moins de viande
on dit que c'est un excès de viande
rouge peut être mauvais pour la santé
est-ce que vous vous faites attention à
ça est-ce que vous êtes devenu
flexitarienne par exemple alors moi je
j'ai des filles qui se sont lancés dans
le végétarien puis qui sont un peu
revenus en arrière pour des questions
peut-être aussi de climat de bifteck
quoi voilà en nous on a été éduqué avec
les saucissons les biftecks les
carbonades vous faites pas donc moi je
mange de la viande je mange aussi des
plats végétariens j'aime beaucoup les
légumes je mange pas beaucoup de viandes
rouges vous savez ces viandes maturée on
a on a des beaux restaurants
partout où on peut goûter des viandes
vraiment de sélection voilà je suis pas
une grande spécialiste mais je mange
bien sûr de la viande j'ai choisi un
plat de viande et vous portez pas
particulièrement cette voix de attention
au climat ou attention à la santé alors
je dirais que je fais mon éducation en
politique c'est-à-dire que au moment de
la campagne législative on a fait la
fresque pour le climat avec toute mon
équipe c'était ses ambassadeurs de de la
vigilance contre la destruction du
climat qui faisait des propositions de
de groupes de travail on fait cette
fraise qu'on travaille sur à la fois les
océans la viande l'élevage et j'ai
beaucoup appris avec ces ambassadeurs de
la fresque du climat ça m'a beaucoup
sensibilisé sur les nuisances de
l'élevage mais comme de l'industrie
textile sur la pollution dans notre
planète et donc oui on fait attention
globalement dans la famille on a évolué
on mangeait plus de viande il y a 30 ans
on en mange beaucoup moins
la filière voilà là je pense qu'il faut
une filière vertueuse résiliente durable
locale et c'est ça qu'on promet en
agriculture de relayer le discours de la
Cour des comptes on en a parlé dans
cette émission qui veut réduire
l'élevage pour réduire de facto la
consommation de viande un peu au forceps
est-ce que vous êtes vous pensez qu'il
faut sonner la l'alarme l'élevage est
polluant et très polluant donc il y a
une réalité qui est devant nous il y a
plein de leviers qu'on doit activer et
des leviers parfois de contraintes pour
faire évoluer nos pratiques les
pratiques de nos industries de notre
agriculture pour des pratiques plus
vertueuses et avec moins d'émissions
carbone mais moi je suis pour des
transitions progressives on l'a vu avec
tout le sujet des pesticides pour les
agriculteurs dans le Nord avec la
betterave les problèmes de la jaunisse
des pesticides interdits puis
réautoriser la concurrence européenne
rien n'est simple le Yaka faucon pour
passer aux pratiques écologiques moi j'y
crois pas je crois qu'il faut être aux
côtés des professionnels faut travailler
sur la transition d'ailleurs
les jeunes producteurs de bière leur
trouver d'autres débouchés quand on
regarde le sujet de la bière par exemple
et de il y a 30 ans la bière c'était 6
litres de consommation d'eau pour créer
un litre de bière aujourd'hui c'est 3
litres toute la recherche l'innovation
aide aussi à avoir des pratiques plus
vertueuses et donc je suis plutôt pour
une transition douce et efficace alors
on va voir maintenant si vous êtes
vraiment incollable c'est le quiz
alors Brigitte j'ose plus dire que
spielbout est né à Lyon parce que
maintenant qu'on connaît l'histoire
c'est vraiment
alors
je disais né à Lyon vous connaissez
forcément la recette de la cervelle de
canut vous connaissez ce plat la
cervelle de canut je connais mais
de la cervelle
qui ressemble un peu à la cervelle alors
il y a plein de petites anecdotes sur
cette cervelle de canut qui est très
connue quand on a non seulement qu'on
est né à Lyon mais qu'on a grandi à Lyon
alors sauriez-vous nous dire si ces
affirmations sont vraies ou fausses
cette recette apparaît au XIXe siècle
lors de la révolte des Canuts les
ouvriers de la soie à Lyon
je dirais oui si c'est originaire de
Lyon exactement et en plus elle
s'appelle cervelle de canut parce que
justement ces ouvriers mangent ce
fromage blanc on l'appelait ainsi car il
remplaçait la cervelle de cochon trop
cher pour ses canuts
pas pourquoi c'est faux parce que
c'était en fait de la cervelle d'agneau
et que les canuts mangeaient puis
ensuite elle est devenue très cher donc
ils ont remplacé cette cervelle d'agneau
par ce fromage blanc c'est le chef
mondialement connu Paul Bocuse qui a
remis au goût du jour cette cervelle
dans les années 70
c'est Paul Lacombe en 1930 qui est un
autre grand chef de la capitale des
Gaules enfin les trois aires de la
recette authentique de la cervelle de
canut sont la menthe l'estragon et le
cerfeuil
je suis j'ai un doute sur la menthe
comme quoi
même mettre à Lyon et rester une journée
difficile
avec un prénom comme le vôtre vous ne
pouvez ignorer que les fleurs s'invitent
parfois en cuisine alors sauriez-vous
nous dire quelle fleur ne se déguste pas
en beignet
à fleur de bananier B fleur d'artichaut
c'est fleur de sureau des pétales de
roses
j'hésite entre artichaut et sureau je
dirais sureau aussi il faut choisir
alors c'est artichaut c'est artichaut
parce que c'est une fleur qui est non
comestible donc impossible de la de la
travailler dans les plats enfin il vaut
mieux pas en tout cas sinon c'est qu'on
vous attendez un piège alors vous savez
violette pilbook en France et bien le
repas occupe une assez large place et
particulièrement en politique j'imagine
que vous l'avez appris surtout depuis
que vous êtes député alors c'est souvent
là que ce nous les deals politiques et
se fait la petite et la grande histoire
c'est la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé de réfléchir à
une anecdote politique autour d'un repas
est-ce qu'il y a un souvenir qui vous
est revenu à l'esprit
oui il y a un souvenir qui m'est venu à
l'esprit c'est
c'est la découverte de la recette du
minestrone avec Martine Aubry d'accord
parce que vous parliez d'elle tout à
l'heure
quand on est en politique quasiment tous
les déjeuners et les dîners sont
consacrés des réunions de travail en
fait on est à table certes mais on bosse
quoi et je me souviens qu'au début de
mes fonctions quand j'ai travaillé
Pierre Mauroy puis je suis arrivée comme
chef de cabinet donc à la mairie de
Lille on avait la chance en fait de
pouvoir faire nos réunions de travail
dans le bureau du maire et c'était et je
leur rends hommage d'ailleurs c'est un
petit clin d'oeil les cuisiniers de du
restaurant municipal qui faisait aussi
le repas pour nous avec le Directeur
Général des Services les quelques dans
le bureau du maire dans le déjeuner dans
une grande table elle n'avait pas de
bureau et donc c'était une table
conviviale et donc c'est quelqu'un qui
aime la cuisine italienne et spécialiste
de ce bouillon du ministre et c'est elle
qui donnait les cours cuisinier pour que
le minestrone soit parfait et c'est
hyper léger c'est une soupe légère avec
plein de légumes etc donc voilà c'est
cette petite anecdote oui alors ça
dépend ça peut être chaud voilà ça peut
être chaud aussi et donc nous tous on a
goûté aux évolutions de ce petit
bouillon mais vous en mangez tout le
temps non pas du tout mais c'est surtout
un bon souvenir de l'échange avec les
cuisiniers municipaux les agents de la
ville parce que finalement de faire la
cuisine pour le maire quand on travaille
à la mairie au restaurant municipal et
pour les invités du maire alors nous
c'était plutôt des repas sains parce
qu'on travaillait mais des fois on avait
des invités qui venaient et c'est
c'était hyper valorisant par exemple des
ambassadeurs d'autre pays
ministres voilà ça m'était en valeur et
donc il y avait souvent des plats
régionaux effectivement et puis des
gaufres des gaufres traditionnelles de
l'île voilà donc ces moments là de
mercelles de merde et puis il y a
maintenant il y a merveilleux enfin il y
a un peu de concurrence il y a même des
bons boulangers Lillois qui font et
pâtisser Lillois qui font la gaufre
chacun à sa recette et mère bien sûr
s'exporte dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui donc c'est très connu mais
voilà en fait le repas l'anecdote en
politique c'est que le repas c'est quand
même un moment aussi de paix à un moment
de conciliation un moment de négociation
et c'est pas comme certains peuvent
s'imaginer voilà on est dans la dans le
luxe on prend notre temps pour manger
pour boire etc on a rien à faire c'est
plutôt le contraire moi tous les repas
enfin on est en permanence en train de
bosser quand on fait de la politique que
ce soit au niveau local quand je suis
conseillère municipal de Lille le seul
moment mes autres collègues dans mon
groupe faire respirer Lille il travaille
moi mais ils ont des par exemple il y en
a ils travaillent dans une collectivité
donc son seul moment pour pouvoir
travailler en politique c'est 12 14 donc
on mange des déjeuners par exemple nous
à faire respirer on fait souvent des
auberges espagnoles c'est à dire quand
on doit on n'a pas de budget spécifique
donc chacun ramène un truc à manger et
moi l'auberge espagnole c'est vraiment
un truc que j'adore pour bosser en fait
et donc chacun apporte ses petits
et puis on parle politique autour de
quand pas de budget commencé quand on
est on se lance on fait ça donc
l'auberge espagnole ça permet alors en
plus il y a toujours plus que la
quantité par personne parce que on veut
montrer on ramène une qui chantière pas
ça part vous voyez on ramène un dessert
et donc il y a souvent plus avoir à
manger on peut goûter un peu de tout il
y a des plats maison puis il y a nos
petits jeunes
jeunes militants qui eux n'ont pas pu
cuisiner mais qui ont quand même pris
une petite salade au supermarché voilà
c'est assez sympa et l'auberge espagnole
c'est des moments voilà de convivialité
et de travail de rassemblement parce que
il faut un peu de plaisir aussi en
politique c'est alors on va continuer à
parler évidemment des traditions locales
et du Nord avec la frite qui accompagne
souvent les plats mais comment repérer
une bonne frite ou la trouver c'est le
dessous des plats
alors c'est une des meilleures frites du
Nord la frite adorée ça crée trois fois
de suite meilleure friterie elle se
trouve à quelques kilomètres de Lille à
Wambrechies là-bas la frite est dorée et
croustillante les clients en témoignent
David qui a reçu Maïté Frémont et Marion
Duvauchelle leur a livré tous les
secrets d'un cornet réussi
[Musique]
je m'appelle David
47 ans les gens qui me connaissent bien
l'appel existe
et mon personnage c'est très rock'n'roll
les beaux gosses
chez David
France trois fois de suite la frite de
David se mange sans chichis on est dans
une baraque
c'est important la petite connerie
comment ça va madame va bien voilà
convivial dans le Nord les 500 baraque à
frites sont une tradition pour les Chtis
c'est quasi culturel
de pouvoir manger juste à côté du
chantier c'est ça aussi ce qui est bien
les baraques c'est que ça s'implante un
peu n'importe où et on n'a pas besoin
d'aller en centre-ville manger sur le
pouce à moindre frais chez David les
clients consomment chaque jour
silos de pommes de terre c'est vrai
qu'elles sont relativement bonnes
croustillantes que certaines frites sont
molles
alors c'est vrai qu'on retrouve quand
même la vraie frite quoi mais quel est
donc son secret après avoir reçu de
Belgique ces pommes de terre fraîches
épluchées coupez et laver David les
plonge une première fois regardez bien
on prend une frite
on appuie dessus
il y a un intérieur on doit sentir une
texture qui ressemble à de la purée
là en l'occurrence la frite est précuite
avant d'être servi mais la clé du succès
c'est qu'elle ne barbote pas dans de
l'huile ni don du gras de bœuf c'est un
petit goût c'est particulier en fait
c'est quelque chose qui reste en bouche
au niveau de la paume de terre et tout
ça c'est un goût ben alors maintenant
quand c'est bon tout le monde trouve que
c'est un goût de noisette voilà ce petit
goût de noisette a tout de même une
saveur amer pour David le prix du gras
de bœuf a augmenté de plus de 30%, tout
comme la mayonnaise et la pomme de terre
[Musique]
quand j'ai vu que le pot de sauce
maillot avait été de multiplié par deux
on va dire qu'un Américain on va dire il
a pris un euro 1,20 € pour savoir qu'une
friterie ou une pizzeria c'est pas un
commerce essentiel ça reste un plaisir
tous les petits plaisirs on en fait plus
où on en fait beaucoup moins si il a
augmenté de plus de 60 centimes sa
barquette David c'est aussi être très
généreux côté portion
[Musique]
ça vous a rappelé des souvenirs c'est
vraiment culturel la frite dans le Nord
déjà c'est pas cher
dans une friterie c'est pas cher et
faire des frites pour toute la famille
quand on a une famille nombreuse c'est
comme les pâtes c'est pas cher donc ça
fait plaisir à tout le monde tout le
monde mange la même chose donc je crois
que il y a déjà ça après bien sûr la
pomme de terre c'est quelque chose qui
est cultivé dans le Nord en particulier
je crois qu'on produit quasiment toutes
les frites de France
oui les achète en Belgique aussi la
Belgique on pourrait revenir c'est des
sujets notamment et au transport
moi quand j'étais petite on mangeait des
frites justement pour des raisons
budgétaires parce que mes parents
faisaient très attention c'était des
frites dans une assiette creuse avec un
œuf cassé au fond donc on battait l’œuf
frais cru et donc
tremper au lieu de prendre la mayonnaise
on c'était le repas
jaune et le blanc d'oeuf quoi ça fait
des protéines avec la pomme de terre oui
c'est très bon c'est très bon les frites
mayonnaise barbecue moi j'aime tout moi
j'aime tout ce qui est sauce
dans cette émission qui nous a demandé
les frites au maroilles ça vous en
manger aussi dans les frites plutôt on
ne fait pas trop à la maison mais on est
frustré moi j'aime tous les fromages
fondus le beurre les fromages les sauces
donc tout ce qui est gras c'est vraiment
mon truc donc mais après voilà moi
c'était vraiment dans mon enfance se
souvenir là en particulier on n'allait
pas nous beaucoup à la barata frites
parce qu'on habitait dans l'île et c'est
ce que j'allais vous demander parce que
on a des friteuses chez soi aussi ou il
y a vraiment la tradition d'aller à la
friterie une fois par semaine à Lille
non à l'île même non il y a une friterie
à Fives à côté de chez moi qui a un
quartier populaire et donc il y a une
friterie à five mais il y en a pas dans
tous les quartiers de l'île il y en a
une à Lille Sud moi j'habitais au centre
ville de Lille quand j'étais petite moi
c'était mon père qui faisait des frites
c'était pas dans les friteuses Seb vous
savez
et c'était une marmite avec un truc
qu'on sortait en faire c'était hyper
dangereux en plus c'est des choses qu'on
fait voilà avec deux bain et faisait
vraiment à la tradition traditionnelle
et c'était la joie les frites c'était la
joie c'est comme la baguette on a acheté
du pain coupé du boulot coupé la semaine
et le week-end c'était la baguette parce
que la baguette c'était plus cher et
c'était et l'Afrique c'est forcément
avec du gras de bœuf parce que nous vous
traditionnellement mais plutôt de
l'huile l'huile de tournesol ça a
beaucoup évolué parce que le grain de
bof sur le plan on va dire diététique
c'est beaucoup moins bon pour la santé
on est quand même dans une région où on
a les moins bons résultats en termes de
santé publique un taux d'obésité
important les Lady cardiovasculaires le
cholestérol donc effectivement depuis
longtemps on nous dit que le gradebeuf
c'est pas très bon pour la santé mais il
y a encore énormément
ça n'a rien à voir essayez les deux vous
allez voir ça rien à voir c'est un petit
goût c'est plus croquant mais on le
trouve encore beaucoup dans des
friteries
à Lille dans le Nord-Pas-de-Calais et
puis on a aussi plein de frites qui sont
passés à l'huile végétale alors je vous
m'apportez votre ma question sur un
plateau parce que j'allais dire Esco non
justement de cette question sanitaire et
de santé publique est-ce qu'il faut
sacrifier c'est ces frites ils font la
tradition du Nord sacrifier donc parce
que non mais quand vous regardez les
études la France gagne reprend son
retard sur en termes d'obésité par
rapport aux populations américaines
anglaises allemandes il y a plus en plus
de jeunes Français qui sont obèses
est-ce qu'il faut pas prendre de temps
en temps des mesures drastiques et
la frite je crois de toute façon
publique la question est provoque
c'est quelque chose dans beaucoup de
familles qui est comme à l'anse où il y
a beaucoup de friterie depuis très
longtemps dans le bassin minier ou comme
sur ce chantier où on avait cet ouvrier
qui disait ça il y a des gens qui vont à
la friterie tous les jours mais
inversement il y a beaucoup de gens dans
le Nord qui vont à la friterie de façon
exceptionnelle pour aller à la friterie
manger fricadellefried les frites une
fois burger frites voilà bah forcément
et donc moi je pense que comme tout
quand il y a pas trop d'excès il faut
pas se priver il faut pas contraindre en
particulier quand on voit le enfin la
friterie Momo dans bien je veux bien
Bienvenue chez les Ch'tis il y a 10 12
ans maintenant c'est une fierté encore
aujourd'hui pour pour nous tous et Momo
à la braderie de Lille il est là
fièrement les gens ils le prennent en
photo ça fait partie de notre patrimoine
donc non on ne sacrifie pas c'est une
question on éduque les enfants dans les
écoles primaires il y a beaucoup
maintenant de travail qui est fait
notamment avec le CHR de Lille sur
l'éducation à l'alimentation à prendre à
cuisiner un légume soi-même dans les
centres sociaux aussi il y a beaucoup
d'animateurs qui font un travail sur la
cuisine pour apprendre à ne pas acheter
des produits transformés qui sont plus
chers et comment on cuisine des légumes
par exemple un gros chou-fleur c'est pas
cher en hiver et on peut faire plusieurs
repas avec et donc je crois que sens
ibiliser les enfants à une bonne
alimentation avec la dégustation et puis
faire évoluer nos cantines avec tous les
impératifs des lois qui nous poussent
vers 20 30 40% de bio et de local mais
on n'y est pas c'est des engagements
qu'on doit avoir mais je ne sais qui
ferai jamais nos baraques à vous parler
quand même de diabète de cholestérol
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas mal de graisse
et est-ce que la friterie c'est pas le
précurseur du fast food un peu en France
je pense que
c'est de la malbouffe la frite moi je
voudrais pas que vous coupiez ce que je
dis et que il reste une phrase comme
celle-là non c'est de la super bonne
bouffe une frite parce que voilà c'est
la convivialité c'est la famille en
général le Corneille il y en a trop on
mange trop enfin c'est voilà c'est un
moment dans la vie ou même quand vous
faites frigadelle frites dans une
baguette avec la sauce andalouse plus
les frites vous voyez bien sûr c'est pas
diététique mais c'est comme toute chose
qu'on va se permettre au moment à un
moment voilà se faire plaisir ça fait
aussi partie moi je pense qu'il y a des
familles c'est peut-être la sortie à
l'Afrique alors fait du bien après
Aller au Mcdo tous les jours non c'est
pas bon pour la santé elle est à la
friterie
parce que là on a des patates qui
arrivent directement de Belgique qui ont
juste été épluchés on la met dans de la
graisse de boeuf c'est vrai que quand on
regarde des bonnes patates dans une
huile un peu c'est pas non plus
complètement dingue par rapport à des
produits très transformés des additifs
des aromates il y a beaucoup de friterie
qui font elles-mêmes par rapport à leurs
pommes de terre qui achètent leurs
pommes de terre
on a quand même 8500 exploitations
agricoles dans les hauts de France qui
font des pommes de terre il y en a
beaucoup qui achètent la pomme de terre
et qui font eux-mêmes les frites donc il
y a aussi tout un truc de toute façon on
le voit on le voit la frite maison enfin
il y a rien de tel et effectivement vous
avez raison c'est pas comme une pizza
toute faite surgelées
peut-être pas la malbouffe et je vais
vous dire on a à l'île une très très
belle histoire la friterie meunier j'en
parle parce que j'y suis très attachée
quand j'étais petite j'allais au zoo de
Lille et aux autres Lille il y avait un
couple
André et Martine qui avaient repris la
petite buvette du zoo qu'il avait
transformé en brasserie friterie donc on
allait souvent le dimanche au zoo avec
mes grands-parents en particulier et
manger une frite à cette première
friterie grande friterie brasserie dans
l'île et quand ils ont perdu la
concession du zoo en 2017 le fils qui
depuis 14 ans fais des frites pour aider
les parents il a ouvert une friterie sur
la Grand-Place de l'île fallait oser la
friterie meunier maintenant il en a cinq
dans le Nord-Pas-de-Calais et il va
ouvrir enfin d'année une friterie
meunier à Paris dans le centre de Paris
et moi j'espère mondiale parce que il a
tout votre camion avec Paul vous
connaissez les boulangeries Paul qui
viennent aussi de chez nous on Apple on
amerte on a les merveilleux de Fred on
sait s'exporte au-delà de l'île on sait
exporter des produits simples bons
familiaux qui résiste au temps malgré
les difficultés parce que tout n'est pas
rose que ce soit pour les commerçants
les restaurateurs les agriculteurs et
qui savent aussi en faire une fierté de
la région qui va d'abord à Paris c'est
toujours la première étape à Paris et
ensuite on va dans le monde entier moi
quand je vois les boulangeries Paul à en
Chine bah oui je suis fière Paul c'est
du Nord
je suis fière alors David il le disait
c'est vrai qu'il y a des problèmes aussi
de prix aujourd'hui parce que tout a
augmenté
il a augmenté avec la guerre en Ukraine
il y a aussi l'augmentation la
mayonnaise nous disait ce teneur d'une
friterie vous avez vu vous les prix
effectivement augmenter c'est plus dur
pour les frites dans votre
circonscription vous sentez que c'est un
peu plus difficile ou bon ça reste quand
même un produit abordable et donc il
compense finalement peut-être avec la
quantité bonne pomme de terre c'est pas
donné effectivement et puis on voit que
bon alors eux ils consomment 200 300 kg
par jour de pommes de terre c'est c'est
inimaginable c'est inimaginable mais
c'est vrai que même si c'est quelques
centimes pour un foyer sur la pomme de
terre on va peut-être moins le voir que
pour une friterie ça va vraiment changer
toute son sous son économie après il y a
pas de friterie qui ont fermé par
exemple dans votre circonscription
au prix parce que c'est pour tous les
consommateurs que les prix ont augmenté
bon ça recommence à baisser mais on a vu
quand même la différence on fait un peu
plus attention effectivement on prend
une frite pour deux parce que les frites
une frite à la friterie du centre de
l'île qui est près du parc Jean-Baptiste
Lebas parce qu'il faisait très beau il
était 14h donc on savait pas trop donc
une bonne friteuse
tout le temps vous voyez que les
restaurateurs forcément avec le service
ils peuvent pas donc on sortait d'un
rendez-vous on n'est pas passé à la
friterie du parc Jean-Baptiste Lebas on
a pris une grosse pour deux et lui il a
pris un Américain et puis moi je sais
plus une des des Américains
cuit je sais pas trop ce qu'il y a
dedans plein de maillots et dans un
sandwich là c'est vraiment non non
imaginez même pas mais on ne sait pas
américain frites c'est c'est la quantité
oui je pense que voilà il y a toute
l'histoire des noms mais en tout cas
voilà à partager donc forcément
j'imagine que sur les friteries c'est un
impact aussi dans leur chiffre
d'affaires bon bah là j'espère que ça va
redescendre et c'est aussi pour ça que
des fois ils vont les pommes de terre
ailleurs parce qu'il est plus grosse
productivités plus on monte dans le Nord
plus les terres sont humides et donc
parfois les les pommes de terre sont
concurrentes de nos pommes de terre des
Hauts de France bon ça va on reste quand
même le premier exportateur de pommes de
terre d'Europe la région Hauts-de-France
on est leader aussi sur le transformer
on a cette huile industries qui font des
frites surgelés à partir de pommes de
terre ici dans le Nord donc voilà ça
reste quand même quelque chose
on va parler d'une autre tradition du
Nord que vous connaissez forcément très
bien c'est la bière elle est inscrite au
patrimoine culturel français mais la
France ne se place que 41e au rang des
consommateurs dans le monde on en parle
et on met les pieds dans le plat
et c'est l'histoire d'une renaissance à
Armentières profitant d'un regain
d'intérêt pour les bières artisanales la
neuvième et la dixième génération de la
dynastie vous devez connaître des modes
cordonnier ont relancé la brasserie
familiale un patrimoine vieux de 4
siècles c'est un reportage d'Hélène
Bonduelle et de Marion Duvauchelle
maintenant
que ça après ça sert elle est quand même
très blanche mais je pense qu'elle va
être un peu plus dorée
on est dans la brasserie mode cordonnier
donc la plus vieille brasserie de France
puisqu'on a de 1650 et j'en suis la
dixième génération alors on a eu toute
une histoire assez avec des hauts et des
bars on a disparu dans les années 70 se
faire racheter par un géant qui est le
groupe AB InBev et l'ancien lancer il y
a 4 ans en famille Armentières là on est
au milieu de nos cubes de brassage et
donc c'est l'endroit où on produit tous
nos bières artisanales
[Musique]
avec 1000 bouteilles par an on est loin
des 300000 hectolitres produits à
l'appel époque de la brasserie
depuis longtemps
historiques mode cordonnée accueillait
plus de 1200 salariés dont Pascal je
fais quand même 32 ans donc je connais
un petit peu tout le bâtiment là c'était
service de la paye
c'est important et ça nous intéresse
d'avoir justement les les rois les
informations les retours les photos les
anecdotes de tous ces personnes qui ont
travaillé œuvré pour la brasserie et
parmi les anecdotes de Pascal il y a
celle de toute une génération les petits
on leur servait un verre de bière au
niveau des des camps de vacances c'était
où limonade ou bière on avait droit à
notre petite verre de bière
c'était la tradition soit Armentières
c'était ça et aujourd'hui que pense-t-il
de la Motte coordonnée 21e siècle
[Musique]
bien le goût d'une blanche c'est ça
franchement c'est des goûts différents
d'avant
l'amertume le je sais pas le goût le
goût est différent
mais c'est pas les mêmes goûts que ce
qu'on produitait avant non non pas du
tout pour Henri et sa famille il reste
donc encore à se faire une nouvelle
place parmi les prêts de 2500 brasseries
artisanales françaises
je vais vous replonger dans votre vie
d'avant celle où vous ripaillez avec de
la bière et du vin alors quand vous
aimiez la bière puisque maintenant vous
avez fait une pause c'était quoi votre
bière préférée vous préfériez les brunes
les blondes ou alors ces fameuses IPA
c'est Indian Pearl moi j'ai pas mal
goûté de IP parce que j'ai un mari qui
aime bien les IP mais il y en a
maintenant qui sont produites ici
voilà donc et puis c'était un peu
exotique etc et après sinon c'était une
blonde parce que moi j'étais très bien
légère donc c'était l'Artois les les
bons simples et puis on a accroît la
Mongie La Mongie c'est la brasserie
Cambier c'est une bière blonde aussi
donc plutôt et si vous avez raison les
blancs chaussures enfin moi je vous ai
dit
vous la connaissez alors celle-là je
l'ai goûté avec parce que Frédéric Motte
qui est dans la famille Motte c'est son
neveu en rien qui est là il est
vice-président de la Région il est à la
Chambre de commerce depuis des années
c'est un entrepreneur voilà qui est très
connu donc vous connaissez la famille
avec lui voilà on connaît la famille
mode vous savez c'est une grande grande
famille quand ils ont repris en fait le
nom pour recréer microbrasserie ils
étaient déjà une quinzaine derrière
Henri pour le soutenir à quitter son
métier et à réinvestir vous avez vu les
cuves il faut quand même une capacité
d'investissement pour une brique
micro-brasserie donc toute la famille
est derrière ce projet pour à la fois
faire renaître le nom et faire la
promotion donc effectivement il y a
quelques loyers Frédéric m'avait offert
une bouteille qu'on a goûté et elle est
elle est très bonne hein
des arrière-granaires et
arrière-grand-mère je vous la fais
goûter oui oui allons-y c'est que vous
buvez pas Ronald Trump
vous vous sentez vraiment oui tout de
suite la différence vous quand vous
doutez une bière artisanale par rapport
à une bière industrielle alors elle a un
côté trouble c'est vrai qu'il a
distingue mais au goût vous reconnaissez
ça tout de suite vous êtes assez expert
effectivement on quand même une enfin
les Brasseurs du Nord c'est hyper
dynamique il y a un accompagnement des
jeunes à lancer des microbrasseries qui
fait que c'est vraiment un secteur qui
en croissance aujourd'hui pourquoi aussi
parce que je pense que les consommateurs
ont envie de consommer local de
connaître ce qui produit d'aller visiter
les lieux de production même à lui-même
on a une brasserie à côté de la mairie
dans des petits biscuits qui se trouve
sur mon brasserie qui brasseur dans
beaucoup de villes de notre métropole
lilloise dans le Flandre enfin les plus
connus c'est dans les Flandres
brasseries Saint-Omer la bière ça
remplace le vin par exemple dans le Nord
il fait chaud à Lille vous allez dans le
centre-ville ou dans les quartiers avec
une bière c'est vraiment effectivement
il y a même encore des gens ça c'est un
peu moins bon pour la santé qui prennent
enfin de la tradition c'était une bière
ou dans lesquelles on trempait les
tartines au petit déjeuner au café le
matin donc la bière fait partie et les
angles de la vie c'est ce qui est de
l'histoire familiale tout à fait et de
l'histoire
[Musique]
c'est toute une un secret de fabrication
long
un art aussi de faire fermenter des
levures alors on a en plus beaucoup de
recherches sur la levure on est quand
même une terre d'innovation et de
recherche dans le Nord qui fait que il
peut y avoir beaucoup de variétés il y a
tout un bien sûr une culture double de
l'orge brassicole qui se re-développent
aussi dans les hauts de France et qui
fait que les gens ont envie de produits
locaux qui sont faits par des
agriculteurs qui ne sont pas loin qui
peuvent matérialiser ce qu'ils mangent
et ce qu'il boivent je crois que c'est
vraiment une tendance de consommation de
plus en plus importante il y a aussi des
gens qui ont envie de changer de métier
et de se rapprocher de la matière de la
nature et donc de se lancer dans un
produit qu'ils aiment bien consommer qui
est le symbole de la convivialité c'est
c'est top et puis
on a aussi vraiment une opportunité dans
les hauts de France c'est le
développement du tourisme brassicole
c'est à dire que il y a beaucoup de
zones rurales il y a la baignoire il y a
tout autour de la métropole lilloise il
y a même dans notre littoral on a on a
des bières et les brasseurs c'est
derrière eux bah finalement des
agriculteurs du terroir de la bonne
nourriture du post levage de la
carbonade c'est valoriser tout un
territoire pour y faire venir des
Anglais des Allemands des Néerlandais on
est quand même une zone européenne de la
qui est au carrefour on est au carrefour
et d'ailleurs il y a un grand projet qui
devrait bientôt voir le jour dans le
Nord il y a deux choses sur la bière il
y a la future cité de la bière il y a un
appel à projet régional il y a plusieurs
territoires qui sont en concurrence
alors moi j'aimerais bien que ce soit en
PVL on en a parlé avec Frédéric marchand
qui est sénateur que vous connaissez et
qui est spécialisé sur le les plans
alimentaires territoriaux on aimerait
bien que ce soit bien sûr dans le Nord
il y a les concurrence
Nord-Pas-de-Calais voilà la cité de la
bière ça va être un lieu de tourisme et
de valorisation tous les producteurs et
puis on a un festival à Lille qui
s'appelle bière à Lille qui existe
depuis plusieurs années et qui permet
justement aux gens de découvrir et
d'acheter tout ce que l'on produit chez
nous donc oui on est très chauvain mais
le nord vous savez c'est l'histoire de
la mine quand vous voyez les je parlais
de la friperie la friterie Momo tout à
l'heure son père il travaillait à la
mine c'est des gens qui ont la valeur du
travail qui savent que il faut
travailler beaucoup pour gagner de
l'argent faire vivre sa famille trouver
sa place dans la société donc quand on
parle de des frites c'est des métiers
qui sont assez difficiles donc voilà je
pense que tout ce tourisme culinaire
brassicole tout ce qu'on va savoir
valoriser dans nos terroirs du
Nord-Pas-de-Calais c'est aussi retrouver
la fierté d'une région qui régit qu'il
rayonne bien plus loin à Paris et aussi
en Europe et on va pas trop s'éloigner
du Nord avec ce dessert vous allez voir
on passe donc au dessert et c'est le
péché mignon
italienne qui depuis qu'elle de quelques
années devient
prétendantes et l'histoire de notre
amitié avec la Belgique on est quand
même une zone transfrontalière dans le
Nord on le sent partout je crois que
vous vous le démontrez là les pommes de
terre belge la bière belge voilà les
Flandres tout ça c'est une histoire
commune une histoire aussi d'ouverture
d'accueil de chaleur et le fait de
mettre des spéculoos dans un tiramisu et
ça veut dire que dans plein de très bons
restaurants des bonnes tables d'étapes
bistrot on trouve la trace de la
tradition dans la
modernités
moi vers le haut c'est parce qu'il y a
du café ça veut dire réveille-moi
quand on fait souvent ses recettes là
après on les adapte à la maison donc moi
je propose qu'on goûte on le garde à mon
avis vous verrez que c'est tout
vous êtes un peu chaud vide pas de café
moi j'en connais avec du café
il est quand même très léger oui et bien
mousseux
donc ça ça fait partie des desserts que
vous savez préparer vous en faites
d'autres au dessus je peux pas mousse au
chocolat des tartes
marlock plutôt gâteau fondant au
chocolat mais en fait les desserts c'est
plutôt pour les enfants pour les filles
ah oui vous vous avez dit que vous
mangez pas trop de desserts
une fois que j'ai bien mangé des frites
et de la mayonnaise vous savez voilà et
puis sinon j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup
la pavlova
que j'ai vraiment finalement découvertes
en Pologne là où je vais en vacances où
il y a les origines de mon mari et la
pavlova c'est des fruits rouges la
meringue un peu de crème c'est très
léger c'est très élégant et ça devient
la mode mais ça c'est vrai que c'est
l'appareil on a l'histoire la modernité
moi j'aime bien cette cuisine enfin on a
plein de nouveaux chefs et puis voilà on
on a une création culinaire en France
moi j'ai valorisé pour mes vœux de mes
premiers vœux de députés un chef qui
s'appelle Jean Drive qui dirige pardon
qui qui arrivait 9e à Masterchef et qui
s'est lancé ensuite en cuisine à
domicile il fait des choses totalement
revisité avec de l'endive du haut-d'ogue
du des parfums japonais etc mais ils
gardent toujours cette trace du Nord
dans toute sa cuisine et elle est
l'alliance entre le patrimoine et
l'innovation c'est un peu ce qui
caractérise le Nord alors vous savez
qu'on finit toujours cette émission en
musique on va écouter quelques notes de
cette chanson que vous avez choisi et
puis vous nous dites pourquoi
[Musique]
c'est plus évidemment une musique qu'une
chanson c'est Sofiane pamar alors moi je
connaissais pas j'avoue est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire quelques mots
Sofiane Pamart c'est un prodige un
prodige du piano premier prix de
conservatoire
lillois et moi que j'ai découvert
tardivement aussi avec son succès c'est
quelqu'un qui fait des créations
originales au piano qui a commencé par
le classique avec avec Chopin enfin
vraiment dans les traditions du
conservatoire et qui est complètement
dans la légèreté la liberté de création
et qui a tellement de talents qu'il
convain rappeur chanteur contemporain de
faire des collaborations avec lui et
qu'il devient très très connu auprès des
jeunes pour moi il réhabilite le piano
et ça sa tonalité classique auprès de la
modernité du coup voilà il fait très
belle collaboration c'est quelqu'un qui
est un peu hors norme et en fait je
découvert parce que il y avait un grand
article dans La Voix du Nord et que mes
filles m'avaient parlé de lui mais j'ai
vu qu'il avait joué au théâtre
Sébastopol à Lille et j'ai raté ce
concert et je me suis dit la prochaine
fois qui vient à Lille c'est en décembre
il faut que j'aille le voir
j'espère voilà j'aimerais vraiment le
rencontrer et en tout cas je vous incite
à le découvrir il fait rêver au voyage
là c'est Paris et il a toutes les villes
on va se quitter en musique avec cette
musique de Sofiane Pamart merci en tout
cas violette filboul de d'avoir à vous
deux notre invitation effectivement
merci chez Françoise qui nous régale
évidemment comme chaque semaine merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis et puis
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro de politique à table
sur LCP
[Musique]